اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من قطاع
غزه اهلا بكم مع استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
المكثف على غزه ارتفاع عدد الشهداء الى
اكثر من
1500 ووزاره الصحه في القطاع طالبت بممر
عاجل لادخال الامدادات الطبيه في حين قالت
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الوضع الانساني
في غزه بالغ الخطوره الناطق باسم كتائب
القسام يقول ان العدو اضعف واجبن من ان
يهجر الفلسطينيين من ديارهم مرتين ويؤكد
ان المقاومه لا يزال في جعبتها الكثير
ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يؤكد ان اسرائيل
تلقت ضربه قاسيه جدا وان الحرب ستكون
طويله سياسيا وصل وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الى تل ابيب والتقى نظيره الاسرائيلي كما
بدا وزير الخارجيه بلينكن مباحثات في
المنطقه تشمل عمان والدوحه ومن جانب اخر
حذر وزير الخارجيه الايراني من تداعيات
استمرار التصعيد وادانت وزيره خارجيه
النرويج الحصار الاسرائيلي على غزه مظاهره
شعبيه عارمه في عواصم عربيه واسلاميه دعما
للشعب الفلسطيني وتضامنا مع غزه
المتظاهرون نددوا بالقصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل وطالبوا بارسال مساعدات انسانيه
عاجله الى القطاع محاصر الى
اللقاء